you know what mark zuckerberg used to
call twitter way back in the day when
both companies were private he called it
a clown car that drove into a gold mine
a company filled with schmucks that
nobody knew what they were doing they
barely keep it going
julian smith welcome to the show
thanks for having me
elon musk's tried to buy twitter julian
what the [ __ ] is going on
uh oh man so everyone i think i'm on the
other side of what everyone else
everyone's like this is catastrophic
because i of course i'm reading twitter
about this
uh i think you know there's this weird
because elon musk is not the founder of
twitter excuse me of tesla he's not the
founder of tesla
but he did take tesla to from where it
is to where
it is today and and
and so there is this there is a
stagnation i'm i'm a small twitter
shareholder there's a stagnation inside
of twitter it's like everyone's wanted
an edit button is like the manifestation
of this like no one everyone wants an
edit button but they don't want to give
an edit button it's like a manifestation
of a stagnation that occurs inside a
company when a kind of sometimes when a
founder doesn't run it properly
so i actually believe twitter is one of
the greatest most amazing things on this
on this earth
and i
so i can't believe i'm about to say this
but i'm for it
i'm for it i'm for who's against it i
want you everybody is against it ah dude
your twitter's fear is completely wrong
look let's give for the people that
don't know what's going on i'm gonna
give you the breakdown elon musk has
offered to buy twitter to take it
private this is from the new york times
article elon musk offers to buy twitter
live updates his takeover bid at
54.20 cents a share comes just weeks
after he became the company's largest
shareholder here's what you need to know
um
twitter's stock price just that the
markets aren't convinced by musk's bid i
don't think i agree with that the new
york times is probably trying to spin it
so elon musk has launched a takeover bid
for twitter offering to buy it for 54
20 cents a share just weeks after he
became the social media company's
largest shareholder mr musk said that
this was his best and final offer
representing a 54 premium over the day
before he began investing in the company
in late january
uh in the filing mr musk said i don't
have confidence in management and that
he couldn't make the changes he wanted
in the public market so at that point i
mean
that's a pretty
damning
uh
comment
from somebody who's kind of just just
arrived in the house hasn't even taken
their shoes off and he's sort of curled
a big fat one out in the middle of the
carpet in front of everybody
i don't like what you can make him for
dinner let me take over yeah
proper dinner this way otherwise i'm
leaving i didn't know because he's
actually posted the the tweet that's
gone super viral i bet that this is the
the
most accessed sec document
uh of all time
by far so he's just tweeted saying i
made an offer linking to an sec filing
which
presumably does that have to be made
public is that the sort of right okay so
this was out there in any case and
rather than him just letting somebody
find this he's decided to get out ahead
of it but it's got in it
it's got some exhibits and i don't know
how
common it is for this sort of stuff to
be shown there in it he says uh this is
him to brett taylor chairman of the
board i invested in twitter as i believe
in its potential to be the platform of
sp for free speech around the globe and
i believe free speech is a societal
imperative for a functioning democracy
however since making my investment i now
realize the company will neither thrive
nor serve this societal imperative in
its current form twitter needs to be
transformed as a private company as a
result i'm offering to buy 100 of
twitter for 54
per share in cash a 54 premium
uh my offer is my best and final and if
it is not accepted i would need to
reconsider my position as shareholder
twitter has extraordinary potential
i will unlock it so presumably you might
be able to explain this better but
presumably what he's doing here is he's
saying um all of the shareholders in
twitter i'm going to offer you a 54
premium on started at 38 premium on the
day before um
however if you don't do that
not only are you going to look like
you've been cooked to your own
shareholders but i'm going to withdraw
my i'm going to dump 10 percent of my
stock back into that all of my ownership
and then the and then the stock will
tank down again
to wherever it was before the elon
mustang in the first place and so it is
and by the way you'll note that the 5420
number includes the the the number 420
which he also
did whenever he said he was gonna bring
tesla private at 420 dollars like maybe
a couple of years ago back when it was
worth much less than that so he said
i've got a private buyer for tesla at
420 dollars a share always this number
420 right why is that and uh
why the number 420 is he's not memeing
his way through
are you sure because are you kidding are
you trying to suggest that elon musk is
using 420 like blaze up day
as i
all that here's what i'm suggesting
actually here's genuinely what i'm
suggesting i'm actually not sure that
he's not doing that but the reason that
i think that this is so interesting is
that
is that um so much of of what you do as
a founder as a ceo as all these things
really in the public sphere so much of
what you do is about telling a story and
people believing in you and honestly if
i can be if i'd be super clear i again
being back to being earlier on every on
everything
when i was i bought tesla stock really
really long time ago and and since it's
like the one thing i wish i had put like
all of my money into but didn't
but but what happens is you're looking
at a company that effectively was
insolvent and wasn't gonna succeed
unless he was able to get people to
believe
and i'll tell you what he's really good
at is getting people to believe in
something and then that allows kind of
like that story to write out and become
dominant and he's good at that like over
and over and over again surely if he's
about to take this company private his
ability to make people believe from a
value creation perspective now becomes
irrelevant people don't need to believe
in twitter as a platform they already
need it the difference with him with
tesla is that he his ability to garner
belief actually then pays out dividends
in terms of the share price
yeah that's definitely true it's a
different story
the main thing that he's gonna i mean
let's assume this is even real right
versus like it being some giant colossal
joke and he's going to be sued by the
sec again which he was when he did the
420 thing in the first place uh
is is then i i think that there's a huge
percentage of employees they're going to
be like i'm i don't want to work for
this company anymore and so you could
see how it like could completely tank
the number of people that want to work
at that company
but it's true
that twitter has a gigantic amount of
uh
the common square
comment uh
commons value that is in fact not
properly unlocked like and
i don't know why it's like people you
know you know what uh mark zuckerberg
used to call twitter way back in the day
when both companies were private he
called it a clown car that drove into a
gold mine
a company filled with schmucks
that nobody
like nobody knew what they were doing
barely keep it uh
going
and it drove into one of the most
valuable opportunities in the universe
that's hilarious so there's a bit at the
bottom
i don't know what this is it looks like
maybe a whatsapp message or something so
this is again this is in the sec filing
right sec.gov archives blah blah blah
and this must be musk as i indicated
this weekend i believe that the company
should be private to go through the
changes that need to be made so
presumably he's teed this up at least
over the weekend um after the past
several days of thinking this over i've
decided i want to acquire the company
and take it private i'm going to make
you send you an offer letter tonight it
will be public in the morning are you
available to chat and then there's a
voice
script he says best and final
a
i am not playing the back and forth game
b
i have moved straight to the end c it's
a high share price and your shareholders
will love it d
if the deal doesn't work given that i
don't have confidence in management nor
do i believe that i can drive the
necessary change in the public market i
would need to reconsider my position as
shareholder this is not a threat it's
simply not a good investment without the
changes that need to be made and those
changes won't happen without taking the
company private finally my advisors and
my team are available after you've got
after you get the letter to answer any
questions there will be more detail in
our public filings after you receive the
letter and review the public filings
your team can call my family office with
any questions can you imagine for a
second that you are
whoever it is that's received this
particular letter at twitter
last night you know it's a quiet
easy wednesday in the middle of april
and out of nowhere like what's up
message from elon musk and a voice note
and you go
all right
hold on a second yeah i wonder what this
is oh elon musk
i i know it's date night baby i i gotta
i gotta look at this yeah yeah just wait
there uh oh elon musk's offering 43
billion dollars
to take my company private i like i said
i own like not a lot of twitter shares
like
not i don't know 10k worth or some
number you know and like
i just want to hold on to them just as a
relic i want to put them on my wall you
know there's like a i didn't i never got
a certificate i don't think you get
certificates anymore
i'm on my wall you're like wow i knew
that i knew knew about this when you
know okay so he said uh what happens
next in musk's twitter takeover offer
this is from the new york times uh elon
musk offered 43 billion dollars here is
what will or or could happen next the
board reviews the offer the board will
work with its advisors at goldman sachs
to review mr musk's offer they will have
to consider amongst other things whether
the deal fairly values the company and
whether mr musk has the financing to
cobble together a deal the board cannot
simply decide it does not like mr musk
as a suitor but they can come up with
reasons why they don't like the bid like
for example his ability to fund it said
stephen davidoff solomon a professor at
the school of laurel blah blah blah the
board announces its decision the board
will likely take up to a few days to
review the offer if it rejects the offer
it can go in one of several ways it can
put in a defense mechanism known as a
poison pill
yeah
what's that
uh okay so the details of the poison
pill
is i
well the concept of it is if you if you
consume the poison pill it will kill you
and so if i understand correctly
it is uh there are there's a huge amount
of these in twitter's bylaws maybe and
by the way you know i
i'm not super familiar with it but
there's in twitter's bylaws there's a
ton of poison pill provisions that
effectively said if a happens if b
happens if c happens
i
this this uh this i guess software or
this this public good so to speak is
protected
and so it's possible
and i don't remember what the poison
pill provisions are but they exist in a
number of different companies um bylaws
and at twitter my understanding is is
there's a huge amount of poison pill
provision there's more more than in most
tech companies because they're trying to
protect it it's wild that that's what
it's called a poison pill it says the
poison pill limits the ability of mr
musk and every other shareholder to buy
up twitter shares in the open market
once it does it could still decide to
sell itself but without the pressure of
mr musk blah blah blah there are reasons
twitter may opt to not do the poison
pill which again i can't believe that
that's even a term uh maybe wary of
potential criticism that poison pill is
deflecting the concerns of a highly
vocal member of its community likewise
mr musk who's reported stake incentive
blah blah blah the board potentially
looks for a white knight twitter has
been looking for a sale ever since it
went public says howard birkenbuilt who
leads the capital markets firm at blah
blah mr musk's latest activity most
likely heightened interest in twitter's
amenability to a deal some private
equity firms may be put off by twitter's
limited cash flow but a number of
technology companies may take a look
given heightened interest in the social
media giant's power and reach um looks
like
the stock price
hasn't it's it's bumped about 10 in the
pre-market and then pulled back a little
bit today it's 15 higher than when musk
first revealed it but is still
down from a 77 high february 2021 keep
in mind like like snapchat went public
sorry that my timeline's a little weird
but let's say six years ago or something
like that
and it has i i believe it's even like
less users but is more profitable and is
trading better and and by the way like
and i i i hate snapchat and i had i hate
evan spiegel and all the people that are
associated with snapchat just just on
principle but but it's somehow despite
the fact that it it went public five
years ago versus public twitter that
went the public much longer over a much
longer time frame
like twitter still cannot get its act
together i like i don't know if if you
personally believe that this is
i have i have always thought of this
company and by the way there's a lot of
people on twitter's board that are that
probably align with this elon musk
philosophy of the founder or someone
with a great deal of value a great deal
a
vision can take it over and make it
better brett stevens who's the co-ceo of
salesforce i think that's his name
drew houston who's the founder of
dropbox i forget the founder of
doordash's name but another dude who's
on the board of twitter and so
along with others jack dorsey the
current ceo twitter so it's like a bunch
of people probably aligned in the
direction of like
okay but what's he gonna do
and there's another that say well maybe
this is good we've been looking to do
this so who knows i mean the 21st
century is weirder than we've ever
than any of us could possibly imagine i
think we can agree on that twitter's
board met on wednesday according to a
person familiar with the situation who
wasn't authorized to speak publicly
hours after elon musk offered to buy the
company mr musk turned down a seat on
the board over the weekend leaving board
members who had recently welcomed him
into their ranks to weigh a proposal in
which mr musk said he has no confidence
in the management of the company but
what i found out was that the reason he
turned down a seat on the board is
because he couldn't have put in a bid to
take over the company 100 percent if god
on the board so that was one of the
reasons that you know twitter a while
ago and then think about you know the
other game that may have been played
here when elon first purchased his nine
percent stake and then twitter goes
oh [ __ ] elon's probably got the wealth
that he might try to take us over why
don't we offer him a seat on the board
because if we offer him a seat on the
board he can't take us over so they're
playing the game because originally
everyone was like elon's whatever a
silent partner he's not contributing in
the way that everybody wanted him to
which really isn't no one gives a [ __ ]
about what he does financially with
twitter everyone's bothered about what
he does operationally culturally uh in
terms of the branding and its policies
and stuff like that and um
yeah man i i was talking to dan from
drinking bros about this literally a
couple of minutes ago i was like it's so
wild and kind of cool
that we have somebody on the planet who
has the resources and the motivation to
do the things that everybody
else daydreams about doing you know
everybody in tech
has an idea about what they would do to
fix twitter which is the platform of
tech in any case yeah i mean i
definitely agree with that yeah and we
also like like founders
are younger than ever with more power
than ever right like keep in mind that
that ascent is more and more rapid than
it ever has been the acceleration and so
for me the person who really exemplifies
this or the pair that exemplify this the
most is patrick and john collison who
run and founded stripe
in
that must be 10 years ago or something
and it's since become a 100 billion
dollar company and it's still private
and then they're like yeah we're going
to try and solve carbon capture
which is like another obviously really
meaningful problem for the earth
and and so you have these people that
still have their um still have a certain
amount of optimism and still have a
certain amount of
of like feeling like they can still
contribute and they can still do
something
30 years ago 40 years ago and before
that it always it may be different to
you but like it felt like
all the people who had this power were
old and cynical and we're just trying to
do like
like hold on to their cash and and get
it to become more valuable and nothing
else well how old is elon musk age
literally 50 years old bro so i mean
elon's elon's not a young guy you know
he's like slap bang in the middle of
what you would expect from somebody
that's doing this sort of stuff the
difference is that he has quite a young
spirit with him you know he's got that
very sort of contrarian heterodox [ __ ]
you to the man dog point of the moon
thing and i dude i'm i'm in for this so
you know
moving beyond what's going on here
there's some stuff about salesforce
tried to purchase twitter and the sale
went through and some other bits you
know everybody can go and read the uh
new york times article if they want to
go and find out a little bit more about
this but um i think
actually first question is this what's
considered a hostile takeover
that's a great question i think the
answer is
uh yes
what a hostile takeover is strictly like
legally speaking i'm not clear on
but the the understanding is that it is
a hostile takeover in the sense that it
is being done without the permission of
any anyone else that's that's involved
and it's effectively like backing all
the shareholders and the board maybe
into our corner
interesting so i'm looking at some of
the biggest replies
uh some of the highest replies here um
[Music]
a man who's willing to spend 41 million
dollars for free speech is a good man
that i can admire someone replying said
if you're paying billions you're buying
speech it's not free i don't know i mean
what do you think the thing that i don't
get
is people's aversion to elon musk
they have a very strong one it's
interesting because like people often
make those comparisons with jeff bezos
too they're like oh like how rich is he
really and they show like an ant and
then a skyscraper and they're like let's
this is you and this is how rich he is
and they show these crazy comparisons
of wealth accumulation that are
admittedly like out of proportion with
the past because of because of tech and
again that acceleration that was able to
happen it happens faster than ever
but then uh there's this automatic
assumption
that all they're trying to do is
accumulate like like money is no longer
valuable to these people and so then you
could think what's the next thing oh is
it power that seems simplistic to me
it really feels like they want to make
the world
you know maybe the languages neutral
languages like in their image and that
could be some good and some bad
but i don't know like
space travel feels pretty good to me
you know and electric cars feel pretty
good to me like admittedly
one of the stories of elon musk is he uh
he i think he made some money from his
previous companies zip something before
paypal or whatever and immediately went
out and bought a one million dollar
mclaren car
and crashed it on his first ride out so
we're not talking about a normal person
but we're still talking about somebody
that has more vision than the average
twitter shareholder i would say more
vision but the thing that's interesting
is
all of the
uh
like new world order accusations that
get thrown at bill gates bill gates
doesn't have as much wealth as elon musk
but for some reason
more people seem to be happy with elon
at least from i guess like the center
right side of the fence certainly seem
to be a little bit more happy with him
because he's kind of cool and young and
hip and does like meme coin stuff
but
i
i just don't know
i just don't know what it i don't know
what people's problem with elon is
overall i don't think he's
said anything particularly
egregious you know
i don't think he's got like a secret
alt-right past i might be wrong right
yeah yeah i'm not sure that that's i
don't think that's the case either but
there there is this thing that happens
and the general attitude in tech right
and it's true everywhere mark andreessen
elon musk like jeff bezos is more
neutral and by the way people did feel
this way about bill gates in the 90s
during the anti-trust
lawsuits that were going on with the
government but it's sort of receded
since then
and bill gates became this dude that is
almost like john rockefeller senior john
rockefeller senior his post-oil
monopoly thing that he did is he went
out and he spent a gigantic amount of
money
uh donating donating it towards uh
mostly medical causes and his his father
was a quack doctor and so he was like oh
okay well medicine needs to be evolved
and all these other things essentially
what bill gates has done
and but these people are these people
are too young for that and and they
still have energy and they're they're
like i can run another company because
when you run one company i haven't run a
company as big as that but i have run
i've raised a lot of money and i've
built companies are meaningful size for
startups you're still like i think i
could do it again i think i think i
could make it better and easier this
time so i bet he still has a lot of that
energy in him there's a a bunch of
replies from gab you familiar with gab
do you know what that is i am familiar
with the website gab yeah okay so um
there's one set of replies counter offer
sell your nine percent twitter stock
invest two billion dollars in gab join
dab's board and let's take them down you
have to consider that bringing free
speech to twitter isn't as simple as
buying it apple and google do not allow
free speech so if you stop the
censorship blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah dude this is
the equivalent of the guys on pornhub
that comment
that comment things saying
oh
if she if i got my hands on her if only
i was in that room yeah dude she
wouldn't know what we got any all the
people that comment on the you know
glamour models instagram pages saying
looking so hot sweetie you go look dude
elon's not bothered about buying gab you
know he's this is the thing is like is
anything off the table at this point
like that that's the part that really
scares the [ __ ] out of me homeboy's
playing in a 50 million 50 billion
dollar
hostile takeover of the largest town
square platform on the world in the
world yeah for sure he you know gab as a
free speech alternative might be fun or
whatever but it just it just seems to me
like a really poor move i think
rumble did the same thing when
rogan got popped by
uh spotify about is it gonna take
episodes down and doing apologies and
things like that and rumble were like oh
we'll offer you 100 million bucks to go
from spotify to us and you think
i understand that when you're sat in a
boardroom that it kind of sounds cool
but when you're everybody else watching
on twitter you sound like the guy on
pornhub saying that you should come to
you should come over to my casting couch
as opposed to the one that you're on
right now yeah and because the plat
those platforms like nothing's gonna
they're gonna become spotify like no
matter how much it like that's been one
and so that's the same thing with
twitter actually the common square it's
just twitter maybe i don't wanna i don't
know about forever but keep in mind like
it is the one place where you can go say
some [ __ ] well maybe not everything
anymore i don't even know about that but
like you basically go say some [ __ ] no
matter how stupid or offensive it may
become
and it is public which by default on
snapchat because we talked about other
social channels before it is not on
facebook it is not
on a medium that's behind paywalls now
so you not even there
i
on clubhouse i don't know that even is
relevant or i mean instagram's
instagram's got the equivalent amount of
access but you are you are right i
understand
i think that overall dude i'm so down
for this i'm down for everything just
but burn it all to the ground right and
let's start again let's go mad max total
scorched earth policy but it'll be it'll
be interesting to see what happens i'm
going to be interested to see how this
and if nothing else dude
the thing that i've taken away so far is
it's cool to have somebody that has the
resources and the motivation to actually
go after this sort of stuff it's i i
enjoy the fact that we live in a world
where someone at least can offer this
out you know it's on twitter whether or
not they want to decide to take this
thing
are there concerns about centralizing
control and ownership underneath one
person who you know let's say that elon
musk gets a a brain tumor in four years
time and decides to mean say that you
know make some ridiculous policies on
twitter and
completely destroy the platform you go
okay yeah maybe that's not good but you
also have centralized control currently
at the moment with someone who's going
through obvious dementia that's got the
nuclear football under his arm so you
know
the centralized control argument i'm not
convinced really really works but i'm
i'm glad it's happening i'm glad that
he's there uh and yeah if he memes his
way to owning twitter then
like
you're right in as much as
at least somebody
at least at least some change drastic
change is possible
right whereas like before
you know i mean the thing is that we say
in tech is like as soon as like a
professional ceo takes over that company
is like there's like nothing ever
happening ever with that company ever
and so this is almost like a
founder-like move
and i'm excited to wake up to the news
kind of i'm more excited to wake up to
that than like somebody punching
somebody on the stage or whatever
happened two weeks ago yeah i i agree um
paul graham's got this quote i think
that i learned from you that says don't
give up and don't get demoralized yes
advice to start is do you think that
there's anything else
that's missing from that
so that's that's part that's from a
famous article called 13
13 phrases about startups and the two
the two ones at the end are like don't
get demoralized and if you happen to get
demoralized don't give up even if you
are demoralized and the reason that he
says that is because startups are like
not rocket science like so long as you
keep going
and you try able to even raise a little
bit of money to keep going you'll be
able to deviate your way to success
and so that's that's actually like
that's why the clown car was able to
drive into the gold mine from the
conversation before because they were
able to get enough money to just kind of
deviate while the thing was skyrocketing
and so the the number one thing that
they say in startups and it's true for
all companies is like get someone to
love you and if someone like i just
didn't know we serve coaches for people
in the context of uh
of my uh that are just randomly
listening to this i i run a company
practice that serves that serves coaches
lets them help them run their business
and so i just onboarded a dude and he's
like my god you're just saved you've
just like
solved so many of my problems and he was
so excited about you you just want to
have one person like that and if you can
get one person like that there's
probably two and if there's probably two
then there's probably ten if there's
probably ten there's probably a hundred
you have a company
and so it's really about and i think he
even says it in the same article
instead of making ten people or a
hundred people
ambivalent get one person who's just
like i can't get enough of this
to
to come out of the woodwork or find a
person like that
what's the difference between a startup
founder and a normal small business
owner because i'm friends with a ton of
small business owners most of my friends
in the uk have businesses of some kind
you're familiar with johnny and youssef
from propane you know they've been
running a company nearly as long as i
have i've been in nightlife since i was
18 years old everybody there was running
their own company and hustling on the
side doing social media doing whatever
it was um
and yet
there seems to be a step change
between
there's something fundamentally
different about a startup founding or
someone that's raising capital that's is
it is it simply the
the sector or the industry that they're
in or is that is there something else
going on that's the difference between
those yeah so the main one is this like
there was a period and actually maybe
it's still true where ever every company
can refer to themselves as a startup but
strictly speaking
it's me probably there's capital in the
bank and the capital in the bank allows
an insane acceleration to occur
and so there's like you know when we
talk we're talking about nightclubs we
talk about anything uh my uh my fiance
runs a pottery studio okay and so no
matter how many people
she gets
to become to try to become customers of
a pottery studio like there's only
certain square feet so there's only a
certain number of seats
and so then you have to start another
place and that's going to be expensive
too so it's like there's these costs and
so from the perspective of finance it's
about the marginal cost for the next
person is almost zero so custom was zero
to bring the next user in it's true for
twitter it's true for stripe it's true
for what's uh
gab it's true for all of them and so the
zero marginal cost for the next customer
or user means that it can grow to
infinity with all with relatively low
costs which means it is uh there's a
chance a small chance that it can become
insanely successful insanely quickly
so quickly that it makes your [ __ ]
head spin
and
that's true for twitter and i've run
companies like that where it's felt like
the wheels are falling off and it's
growing so fast so that's the essential
difference speed scalability speed and
scalability ideally okay yeah well i
it's just i find it very very
interesting because
again i wonder how many of the guys
i don't have that startup i don't know
whether it's that i'm not in the right
circles i've definitely started to be
around them since i've been in austin
but some of the people that i've met
that run startups are
total drugs like these people couldn't
hold a candle to some of the operators
that i've had that have either worked
for me or worked with me and you think
like the shrewdness that the boys have
got that i am their executive function
their ability to be able to see and uh
be agile and predict and
charm people all that stuff right yeah
um and i really do wonder whether if if
we were able to um switch roles for a
little while and i could pick kind of a
dream team of the people that i've
worked with over the last 15 years and i
could throw them into startups and i'm
sure that there's you know there's tons
and tons of people who are unbelievably
shrewd operators when it comes to their
small
uh plumbing company gardening company
that they run their dog grooming
business their online coaching uh
fitness coaching thing and you go okay
here's a hundred million dollars of seed
capital and a pretty good idea let's see
what you do um so it does seem to me a
little bit like
kind of first mover advantage right
place right time and then and then
presumably as well a little bit of um
people having an existing
reputation
of being a person that is a founder that
gets more opportunities because you're a
founder or a startup or an investor or
an angel or whatever i agree with all of
those things
the higher the margin of the customer
right the more money like the less cost
you have per incremental customer the
more you can [ __ ] up
basically straight up that's basically
the difference so if you're running a
business where you will you make a
dollar and you have to pay 90 cents back
for that dollar you've got a tiny amount
of money to make which means you have to
execute incredibly well the most ex
the most
important example of that is a
restaurant a restaurant is an incredibly
difficult business to to run you make
five percent margin 10 margin maybe if
your place is full it's a really hard
hard business to run and if it's running
properly you just die
so what happens with startups is giant
amounts of capital become accessible
which performs which gives you an
opportunity to [ __ ] up over and over and
over again
you can become a good operator
but you just don't have the amount of uh
the amount of discipline that you need
in real industries oh because you've got
more degrees of freedom to mess up
that's right and so the primary reason
that you need that ability to [ __ ] up at
the very beginning is because you
actually don't know who you're surveying
typically like online yourself is a good
example online coaching business you
know who the next trick or mental
customer is you know how to get the
first one
you're like okay you know the referral
business like maybe i'll get another uh
referral after that startups are filled
with ambiguity we're going to come up
with this insane idea it makes no sense
but randomly some dude is going to give
you 500k to go for it
and so that brings me to the other
element not only they're probably
they're probably a poor discipline and
if they had real world experience they
would have had better discipline in the
first place right
but also
the other element is they having
typically the ceos have really good
uh
ability to to storytell and so they are
able to go to any random dude and i had
to learn this skill right i had raised
zero before in my last business and i
learned that my
that my book writing and my public
speaking skills
could be used to raise money and i was
able to raise 150 million dollars in my
last business in order to
to prove that out really
and and so then you've got this
incredible ability
to try and build something
that you just don't get in the real
world okay so let's say we use the
pottery uh example um
if you've got a pottery studio where
you're you're coaching people to do that
because the scalability is so effortful
because for you to go from one studio to
two studios you're going to need to
find another place you're going to check
with building regulations you're going
to have to staff it and stock it and do
all of these things
being a good storyteller to unlock more
capital to you still has a bunch of
headroom that you're bouncing off a
bunch of ceiling that you're bouncing
off because it's still very effortful
for you to scale the business regardless
of how much capital you have yeah so
this is one of the okay interesting
cause dude i have some people you know
think about again going back to
nightlife my my industry
some of the ways that our guys on the
street that are doing pr-ing i'm sure
you've walked down a busy night like the
streets like broadway in nashville or
whatever like hi mate where are you
going tonight do you want to come in and
they're trying to give you a wristband
some of the narratives that they weave
they're very very quickly able to work
out what is it that this person wants
from the night out that they're going on
tonight are they on a birthday party
with the girls and they want to go
somewhere that's girly and cute are they
out with the lads and they really want
to pull are they looking for a cheap
night are they looking for a fancy night
they're very very quickly able to
work out what it is that they want and
then weave a narrative that tells them
exactly what they want to hear offer
them a deal that closes and then do the
cta like okay so you're going to go up
there you're going to turn right you're
going to blah blah blah show this to the
guy in the front door um so again like
it's just interesting how different
industries um
unlock or enable different types of
skill sets and the only difference is
that
the guys that are working on the street
are making a pound per entry
or whatever yeah whereas the
startup founder ceo is raising you know
perhaps
hundreds of thousands of dollars for
every time that he sells his vision in
the best way as well and and that brings
us to maybe like another
important
thing that i actually you know i was
brought up in a pretty working-class way
my father was an executive coach but it
wasn't like a super lucrative business
as far as he was concerned and my father
and my mother was a secretary and so i
grew up in the public
regular school system what i mean is
public and britain i think means a good
i grew up in a regular school system and
so i just didn't have the network around
me of entrepreneurs and successful
randos
that a lot of these startup ceos come
from and they come from these worlds
where it is possible
to look left and look right at like a
dinner party that your parents are
having and
you're like oh wow there's a successful
like cfo of a public company that my
friend that my parents are friends with
dude on the street
literally doesn't know anybody like that
and literally has no concept of an
entrepreneur which i basically didn't
have until i was 25 either well the
other thing that you don't have even if
you're in that room so a good example of
this when i was in new york i went to a
a couple of dinners that i
uh was a new world a bit of a new world
for me and i was sat certainly around
people that
have tons and tons of capital that
they're prepared to invest in things
i've got nothing for them to invest in
they're not going to give me i mean i
don't need half a million pounds to
to expand my nightlife business because
again we're limited by the number of
people in each city we're limited by the
number of venues that we have and
licenses there are real world
constraints that stop us from doing
things yeah so there's a sort of a
two-way street going on here not only do
you maybe not have access to the people
but even if you did have access to the
people their money wouldn't be able to
do anything for you
either yeah that's dude this is it's a
very interesting way to look at things
it almost makes me think that everybody
that some sort of entrepreneur or is in
a good position to have access to people
like that should have some sort of
startup in their back pocket
just so that that they can pull it out
correctly yeah yeah man you know you sat
at the right table and you go well yeah
actually do you know what it is i've had
this thing and we've been taking over
for a while and it's blah blah blah
we're about to go full time on it again
yeah we're about to go full time on it
and actually we really believe that
there's this unconquered market for
random thing and uh
it's we're actually just looking for uh
somebody and a few people who will be
able to give us the initial seed capital
and then my team will come together and
we believe we can get it to like a
million users or we believe we can get
it to half a million in error you got to
know the code the way to talk
immediately if you have that what
happens with and by the way this is true
for elon musk to sort of bring this
thing full circle is people like elon
musk but less busy than him and
obviously less rich but rich enough
are are looking for and this is like
maybe an
insight or a weird thing for some people
but they're they have places they're
looking to put money and they don't know
where to put it they're literally
sitting around with so much cash going
like i did randomly i'm not one of them
you're like uh i'll buy twitter stock is
like what some rando dude will say but
others have put all the money in the
stock market that they want another they
still have it and they're like i gotta
give it to people and make it grow
somehow well think about it that's where
right think about angel list right what
is angel list like angel list is
basically a a platform for people who
need money to access people who have
money that want to give it away
exactly right and then syndicates
are
some dude literally like yourself or
like myself who's like i know a bunch of
rich people that are on my list and then
i've got these entrepreneurs and i met
them once and we're going to give them
250k
that's that's i mean that is what angel
list syndicates are and
it and the amount of money that flows
uh through the ecosystem is sometimes
like
by the way i've been in this i've been a
ceo startup ceo for like 10 years at
this point but even today it baffles me
we had a really good lead investor for
our last we raised 10 million dollars
from a a fund called andreessen horowitz
which is really good
andrew chen's been on the show yeah okay
andrew's been on your show great yeah so
and so andrew is my lead investor at
andreessen horowitz and the moment that
andreessen horowitz became the lead
investor literally i would get on the
phone just like this like a like kind of
a skype or or google hangout and people
would be like well you're in the
driver's seat how much do you want
and there would be no other conversation
needed because this capital is just kind
of randomly sitting around so actually
this brings me to the core thing about
startups which is
the really what the startup world needs
is more good ideas it doesn't need more
money
it needs
people
little elon musks this is kind of i mean
here we are talking about it
little elon musk that are willing to do
crazy things and by the way this is why
adam newman of wework
was so successful is he just spoke to
this crazy unbelievable industry real
estate that nobody knows how to [ __ ]
with but that everyone hates
and he's just like yeah he's like you
know what we have billion dollar
companies and he was like you know what
doesn't exist a trillion dollar company
i'm gonna make a trillion dollar company
and people would look back at him and
they'd be like i [ __ ] believe him i
believe him
i and and here's the problem
here's the problem that i have with it
man like i understand that somebody like
that can give a compelling narrative you
know i had
a guy who wrote the downfall of wework
on
about a year and a half ago and that
story about adam newman is is crazy and
compelling and i understand that he was
a great speaker
it makes me feel very very sad there are
there are people out there who have that
amount of capital
you know
hundreds of thousands millions tens of
millions or if your softbank's case like
hundreds of millions of dollars to be
able to throw around yep
and they're so stupid that they're
prepared to do it based on some guy's
charm i understand
you've you've literally you've brought
it to essentially what it is
and it the reason that that's the case
is because out there in the world a lot
of these people most of these people
have seen some crazy thing happen
that they were not ready to believe
within it maybe the most relevant
example is one of them being bitcoin
like everyone is just like it's called
what oh it's called bitcoin you're like
okay
and it became what oh it's like one of
the leading currencies in the 21st
century is
and and so you've got these
these stories these unbelievable stories
that are out there and when people miss
these investment opportunities they then
go well i gotta [ __ ] throw my money
at the next one yeah okay this seems to
be kind of like a um
this
inherent
ability this sort of artistic ability to
clairvoyantly see
talent in someone right you hear these
stories about you know i heard the
founder and i just knew that he was
going to make it work and you go well
this is and that's the bit that gets me
i think
surely the business fundamentals
are more important surely the
uh
potential size of the market surely the
overheads versus the growth gp that you
can make on each transaction surely
the liquidity pick anything right
anything that isn't whether or not
homeboy manages to keep eye contact with
you during this conversation like that
that to me should not be the main
determinant and
it just surprises me that people who
have so much capital
do not use any more rationality than the
rest of us and you'll know jim
o'shaughnessy from oshona the asset
management
very good friend met him in new york a
couple of weeks ago and he said to me
look me in the eyes and he's like chris
it's idiots all the way up although this
is exactly what i was going to say it's
it's literally doesn't matter how high
you go the people are still dumb and
don't know what the next thing is and
they don't know what's coming
it's crazy
man it blows my mind so we were talking
before we got started about your um
perennial ability to
be
a first mover slash almost so early that
it can be both an advantage and a
disadvantage can you kind of lay that
out
i i think um well i mean the the
examples there's a lot of examples but
like maybe the
podcasting is now a gigantic thing i've
started one of the first podcasts in
2004
right many many years ago and i remember
thinking oh the world's gonna get gonna
get transformed oh my god this is gonna
kill radio the same things that people
say literally 18 years later which is
wild to think about and so i have a lot
of examples like that in my life and
i've learned to i've learned to to
push
that
that characteristic of mine and to be
like wait wait okay but what's actually
going to happen in 12 months though
so that i'm not
thinking that the future was so
radically change
i'm now conscious of
probably one of the top qualities of
humanity which is it just wants things
to not change that much and it wants
things to change like a tiny bit so when
we innovate
uh we try to innovate 10
or 20 at my companies that i that i
built versus 50 100
i
you can you can innovate 50 100
5 10 years down the line
but
you gotta
you got to give people a little bit one
step at a time yeah i mean so i've got a
friend sky uh good buddy of mine out
here in austin and he's trying to
completely revamp the way that the
advertising model works by using polka
dot right on the blockchain and
what he's trying to do is he's got this
complex plan which i can't really
explain or understand but it's i
understand he's trying to capture all of
the area under the supply demand curve
for potential advertisers rather than it
being at one particular price point even
if you have a dynamic buy on an ad on
the back end it only moves a little bit
right you can't capture the entire area
underneath right curve um and
we've been talking about this and he's
like dude i
and i really really appreciate his
vision and i have other friends that uh
got this they're super excitable and
they're so positive about things and
it's really inspiring because i'm
british so like
genetically that's kind of contrary to
to how i'm programmed but
we had a chat uh a couple of weeks ago
and he was like man i i think i might be
kind of trying to make too much of a
leap here i'm trying to basically
reimagine the way that advertising is
done and the technology that i'm trying
to do it on has only just been finished
four months ago i'm like yeah yeah so
that kind of speaks i guess in a similar
way to what you were talking about that
people need to be led cultural change
especially in the business world
especially with unproven products
especially with
state changes and complete sort of
shifts in the way that things operate
it has to be done one step at a time
people need to have proof of concept
which is strange because in other areas
like give me some money
proof of concept doesn't necessarily
need to be shown but when it comes to
adoption
it does yes
yes so the adoption needs to be what do
we do in the next three to six months
this is what the best entrepreneurs do
they're like what can i do in the next
three to six months
and then but how can i sell
and how can i raise money on the 10-year
the 20-year vision or i thought you know
some some people like we're going to
build a hundred-year company everything
is a sales pitch okay we're gonna build
the first trillion dollar company this
may be an adam newman i don't remember
but
those are like those are the this guy
has a crazy vision it's unbelievable
even though it's just words right but
words have an incredible power more than
i ever thought i when i wrote books i
was like i was like that's storytelling
like that's not a job i would laugh at
people they'd be like i'm a storyteller
but i was like oh my god it's actually
one of the most powerful jobs in the
right space that exists so if you're
able to tell a story
that has incredible value in the right
place list but then if you execute the
way that a restaurant does right super
interval okay what do you how do we do
the next thing really quick everybody
has a job every job is well managed
everybody knows how to do it everybody
everything falls into place now you've
got a really well-oiled machine and
that's the job of a startup ceo actually
is to take that capital and then try to
execute on de-risking that machine until
it's incredibly well understood and you
can put it in a spreadsheet
there's an extension on google chrome
called tweepy i think it's called and
what it does is whenever you go onto
somebody's profile it gives you the
highlights of their most
uh liked tweets from all time uh and one
of the highlights that i pulled up from
yours is something very similar to
something else i tweeted the other day
so easy to dunk so hard to build yeah
what do you mean by that
uh so i mean this is this is for some
reason this is really
a really popular or offensive tweet to
some people but basically it's like it's
so easy to
it's so easy to talk [ __ ]
about other people's things it's
actually one of the reasons when you're
so early to things right uh people are
like that's [ __ ] dumb and luckily for
me i have friends it's funny thing to
say but i have friends that are like
that's [ __ ] dumb julian and and
they've been that way for so long that
are otherwise really respectable people
but they will do that again and again i
write a book they're like i'm not going
to [ __ ] read your book so
so it gives you this really good
humility but also it gives you this
incredible perseverance that no matter
when people say no to you you're just
like i'm gonna keep going i believe i
believe that internal belief is also
like another element of making sure that
the company works or that your vision
comes true you have to keep the internal
belief
while making sure you don't quite
believe all of your own [ __ ] i know
that you have worked with seth godin in
the past and he had a thing that he said
in his most recent book where he's
talking about
a lot of the time you need reassurance
from the world especially the first time
around and i really really love this
insight because there's this sort of
belief that we're supposed to have an
unwavering
self-powered
uh
gusto that's just going to carry us
through whatever the problems are that
we're going to encounter but the reality
of this is that if you don't know that
you're going to do something
having self-belief that you're going to
be able to get through it with no
evidence yet
yeah is kind of the same as delusion and
after a while i have a concept called
imposter adaptation which is the reverse
it's when you continue to disprove your
um imposter syndrome in the real world
and yet it persists so that's when it's
been too chronic but on the first on the
first side of it let's say that you're
new to the market or you've just taken a
change in jobs or you've just pivoted to
some other other sort of pursuit like
how do you know that you're going to do
well and with that in mind it's a much
more i really like the idea of look the
first time around try and get people
near you that are going to say yeah dude
i i think that you can do this this is
doing well get some feedback from the
market over time what you can do is
become as pig-headed as someone like
elon musk
that believes that he can go out and buy
one of the biggest probably the single
most important social media company on
the planet in terms of how the
platform's used
because you have
whatever 30 years
of consistent daily interactions with
people where you maybe weren't sure how
you were going to get on and come out
the other side but
in the first instance you need a little
bit of backup i really like that yeah
and by the way if you have that around
you like the younger you have it
the crazier you can become because then
it's like like if your mother thinks you
were a little prince when you were young
you know which i definitely have a
little bit of that that happened to me
it's like oh my god i'm invulnerable
then all of a sudden like you cut your
hand you're like what how is this
possible
you know it's so you you need to have
some foundations
this is why executive coaches to tell
you the truth for ceos are so valuable
it's because it's someone internally
that's going to be like i will give you
the self-awareness that's needed i will
help keep you on track one of the things
that people often believe about elon
musk and these others is that these
people are invulnerable and they're solo
uh you know they're these just
solo climbers individuals
yeah they'll climb mount everest by
themselves with no ecosystem to surround
them but when you pan the camera out
what you what you actually see is a
gigantic
like support system it's just not
visible
when elon is tweeting [ __ ] on the
internet but actually he's incredibly
well surrounded and so
i
you need a combination of
this raw unvarnished pain from the
market that really gives you a sense as
to what how reality is going but at the
same time like you need to be able to
step away
and do like self-soothing or co-soothing
right in order to keep the momentum
alive if you believe yourself too much
you might go on for a really long time
about something that's fundamentally
worthless and actually the more money
you raise and the more
runway you have so to speak the more you
might waste your time for like years the
deeper the deeper that you're going to
dig the hole yeah yeah famous example of
justin khan uh who shut down his second
company forget the name in the moment a
legal company but because his first
first company first famous company was
twitch and he sold it to amazon for a
billion dollars
people just threw a hundred million
dollars at justin right
and he was like yeah i'm gonna build a
whole business and there was like a
hundred people
and a hundred maybe even more and then
he was like oh actually we never found
anything that anyone liked but he had
spent 50 million dollars in a crazy
amount of money because people just let
him do that i'm just looking at the
market valuation of twitch now
um
it's got the users what do i how do i
why is it so hard to work out oh is
twitch is twitch private it's private it
was bought by amazon yeah it was bought
by amazon for 970 million on august the
25th 2014.
and it's currently got in 2018 it had 62
million users so it's probably got
it's going to have an absolutely insane
number now what's it say here
two million average concurrent viewers
on twitch in 2020 so that was two years
ago uh
two nearly two billion monthly watch
hours
uh how many are watching video games
yeah why can't you tell not all
i don't know how many years oh there it
is um 15 billion dollars current market
valuation of twitch according to some
estimates and that was 2020 from
qzed.com so yeah man i mean
this whole world i i find very
interesting i had jason calacanis on the
show maybe like
two and a half three years ago
and i really just
i really didn't get it then and i kind
of still don't really get it now but i'm
starting to see at least a little bit of
the framework of how
everything gets pieced together
uh but look dude i appreciate you i
appreciate your time today where should
people go if they want to find out more
about what you're up to
i
i mean twitter is the is the public
square so twitter.com julian i was early
to that too
and uh
and then my company a software company
that is uh manages stuff for solo
printers especially coaches
practice.doom that's about it you can
look me up i'm all over the place so i
appreciate you man what's happening
people thank you very much for tuning in
if you enjoyed that episode then press
here for a selection of the best clips
from the podcast over the last few weeks
and don't forget to subscribe
peace